welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz today I'm
joined by Alex Cooper who is the
managing director of Ernest hunter green
who are a sales marketing and finance
recruitment business that operate a
complete remote model and did do this
before
Kove ID's they're 5 years old and
currently have seven people in the
business Alex thank you for joining me
OSI we plan to do this face to face
don't we didn't happen yeah I mean I'm
back in London I'm feeling excited back
in the office and I work from a
breakfast dining table anymore breakfast
bar which is great and not doing podcast
in my bedroom anymore which is quite
nice but yeah really excited to sort of
uncover your journey so far know that
you're someone that has been sort of
talking and being really passionate
about building a fully flexible
McCrimmon business and I think that's
something that's obviously really become
important to a lot of people with all of
us having to do that so I'm really keen
to sort of talk about your journey today
as MD of an Atlanta green so we're
always like to start is how did Alex
Cooper enter the the world of
recruitment let's start there well by
design um I was coming out of university
and had a couple of mates who were doing
pretty well in in recruitment
I studied sports science and had dreams
of kind of running a gym and being a
personal trainer and these kind of
things but being reasonably money
motivated it wasn't it didn't appear to
be a lot of money in those areas so I
looked at for evidence of people making
decent money and had a couple of mates
who were doing pretty well in
recruitment and started applying for
roles in recruitment and went to a
meeting with a a wreck to wreck who
placed graduates into
to recruitment and they ended up hiring
me to do that job I really yeah so I
actually started out in brick as a wreck
to wreck
Grayson graduates into recruitment oh
wow okay so just to set the scene then I
thought what was the journey up until
the point and you started your own
business so you were to that first
company for how long was it like two
years
well I I did I did three years there so
why I sort of transitioned there so I
did Bret direct for a little while and
then but that was quite alien to what
the rest of that business was doing
because they are they actually focus
predominantly on PR agency recruitment
some rectorate was quite separate to
that so just forget Alex and he's a
graduates piece of grass that means
recruitment well they had they did have
a division doing that when I joined I
kind of 5050 but as over time the
rectorate business kind of just stayed
the rest of it group so I wanted to go
and do that because they were making
much bigger fees and and it seemed a lot
there was a lot more potential there
plus it was pretty much on my own at
that point so I then transitioned over
to be to actually be a sales and
marketing recruiter working on the
client side basically opposite side of
those agencies but again found myself
being reasonably I isolated so I then
moved to company called PS deeds via
sales and marketing recruiter which is
what I've done ever since okay nice okay
it started in that must have been an
interesting first year in recruitment
then how was that
well actually I mean the first year I
mean the first year was was was really
good but really I had no idea it was
2005 yeah it was I had no idea what I
was doing but because recruitment
companies were hiring so quickly I was a
graduate all my candidates for graduate
I I could build a wall with the
candidates really quickly there was
never any shortage of jobs or anything
like that so it was really I mean in
some ways it was
quite easy introduction to the industry
richer a lot of my real earnings came
far later in my career because it it was
it was really a case of just trying to
get your hands on anyone decent and you
could charge almost what you wanted for
them because everyone needed yeah so it
was it was really good yeah and I
probably did that for a couple of years
actually and then an in transition later
on probably when things got a bit harder
and yeah and as I say I've been in sales
and recruitment marketing with cream and
ever since okay so so interesting sort
of first experience that I'm working for
a business and recruitment and then or C
as you said Jorun PSD looks like you
worked there for just under four years
then join another business for just over
sort of free nearly three and a half
years yeah so really yeah I mean nearly
a decade of recruitment experience
before you saw took the leap to to start
your own recruitment business and I
guess I mean looks like you obviously
joined PSD 2008 what was that like yeah
I think I do it in my and Lehman
Brothers collapse in September for
memory and I yeah I didn't really know
what was what to make of this this was
obviously completely new experience but
yeah PSD had I really I joined there to
go to a much bigger business which had a
sort of more mature environment in many
ways so and and that is exactly what it
had so had some really experienced
people who were really good mentors and
really good for my development
throughout that time and and I kind of
and they really did help me actually
because that's they moved me into the
technology division yeah which was one
that was doing a little bit better in
those times and that's and I have now
been in technology seen in that whole
experience in the Hammond
lasting impact on someone who ended up
doing and there's no way you started
building here well absolutely and and I
work there with Elliot who I left PSD to
join at Berkeley Mead so Elliot
Sanderson who is one of the cofounders
of Ernest hunter green had left PSD to
go to Berkeley Mead and to set up a
sales and marketing practice there I
left to join there and then for three
and half years later we decided
something here so that that moved to PSD
ended up sort of you before doing some
really good relations to people that
you've ended up and that's interesting
what one point you just mentioned and
around sort of got access to some great
people and the sort of mental [ __ ] piece
is that is that something that you sort
of actively look for when you join that
business because I think so what was
your mindset or why do you think you was
able to sort of form good relationships
or get access to or get people willing
to sort of help you because I think
that's that's something that a lot of
lot of recruiters one access to better
people or do want a mint or whatever but
how did you go about that
yeah so I joined there really because it
was had far it was much much much bigger
company and it had yeah it had a lot
more structure to it but in terms of
progression opportunities but yeah
training and development so which was
and that's from a side of things was all
all fine but he's actually in hindsight
that I realized that value that I got
from a mentoring level which was in many
ways unofficial yeah from from different
people within that business so yeah it
just sort of happened I wasn't
necessarily aware of it at the time if
I'm interesting yeah but he's definitely
something that in hindsight I have
benefited from so I Ely something I
would certainly advise people to if
you've been looking back though why do
you think they was willing to help you
because I think a lot of recruiters will
sit a lot this had come up quite a few
times where people wouldn't help but
like they're they're not they feel a bit
nervous about going out
Miller and saying hey Alex like what do
you think about this or whatever do not
I mean but looking back why do you think
that you were some of these people
willing to give time to or help
I took a questioner I I was certainly
someone that worked hard and was very
dedicated and committed yeah
I'm certainly not someone who is you
know sort of I wouldn't say I'm like a
natural salesperson right so I have to
work quite hard at it and go through
processes and do that sort of thing so I
think that probably the hard work was
recognized and yeah and there was
probably a little bit of luck again in I
when I was moved into that technology
division that happened to be working
directly alongside the biggest biller
in really it's actually might be the
biggest parameter in the whole company
at the time but certainly within the
marketing and sales team so I I sort of
fell on my feet a couple of times I
would say yeah so just on that what just
think again thinking back and we'll move
on but and what what stood out that this
was this Elliot that you're talking
about or was it someone else no no no no
this was someone else I'll see it was
he'd been exposed to when you were -
hanson search and early on and then we
should work on the PSD looking back why
why do you think that person was the top
villain and the top 1% on that company
um they they had a lot of rigor in their
in their processes they worked they
worked a lot longer hours than anyone
else
yeah so they had it yeah they had a
ridiculous work ethic they yeah and they
and they just kept very disciplined I
suppose you would say so yeah so you
wouldn't see them in the pub as much you
you know they were always pretty much
the first part when you go in the office
they were in the office so I think they
that's what worked for them it was just
real discipline hunger Drive hard work
and
and and they were very knowledgeable as
well about them the markets that they
worked in I had real deep understand so
it seems like they the newer thing had
to do exactly what they had to do each
day to get the outcomes that they wanted
and did that rinse and repeat
exactly yeah I don't think it was
anywhere was noted sort of genius in it
was real real to the park RAF and yeah
exactly repetition repetition okay
interesting
so obviously then then obviously join
and then obviously left that company
it's obviously join Elliott who soon
obviously if you also need then go
really good relationship with yeah and
just quit one than that because we'll
see that that that happens quite a long
recruitment what what made Elliott
someone that you wanted to follow from a
leader perspective so we I've never been
managed by Elia in any way he and I had
always got along and had of sort of
reasonably I suppose similar attitude
towards just things in general so we
just got along he was working for
Barclays made which at the time were
looking to recruit people like us across
all so there's gonna be a sales and
marketing guess there was a finance test
there was a charge cetera but they were
owned and they were quite a small
business so there was a real start-up
field but they had loads of investment
are owned by PLC okay so they were
pumping money into marketing and this is
one of the things that PSD weren't
necessarily very keen on they were very
sales oriented business so when you when
you recruit marketers and talk to
marketers all day you do so so that you
know that was if that was a big drive to
city we'd have more investment at war
more elemental resources behind us and
the PIA PLC has an unbelievable
structure which and I mean you you
really just got to go and do the
recruitment side of things there he
didn't really have to do anything else
there wasn't really so some really
exciting right yes and some really good
growth opportunities then and
and learnings that could come from that
and okay so obviously then work
therefore the sort of three and a bit
years and I guess just just a quick one
just says we're talking about that if
you think about it so I mean from I'll
see you or see now obviously actively
hire for your own business but I think
it's really common to see and you've
probably seen that where on someone's CV
or all sort of experience will be they
let's say for you for example you work
you go into recruitment you work two
hands in search for three years and then
you're thinking right a is is this has
to offer
maybe we're doing a bigger business like
PhD or whatever and typically what I see
a lot of the time is that that that
recruiter will leave but and then end up
working that new company for like three
months six months all over there might
end up moving again
or whatever so I guess just looking back
and I'm also talk about the Ernest
hunter green piece and so white at the
leap and all that that sort of what what
was going through your head to sort of
help you make sure that you made a good
decision in terms of moving your career
forward and you didn't end up being
someone it just ended up working the
recruitment agency for six months or
yeah because that happens a lot so I
guess was there anything looking back
that you sort of really made sure that
you identified so you just said about
bottling me than the opportunity but so
you had solid stints at each place do
not I mean so I guess was there anything
looking back when he was looking or
think in the air maybe I will look at
other opportunities what what was really
important to you when an interview
process maybe or when you met people
what you when you're thinking about
leaving that you really made sure that
you understood what he was getting into
and when DeRay yeah I think they would
it was what I need him personally from a
company at those points in time so the
move to pierce team for me was about
moving to a bigger company which had
which was a more mature environment so I
would I would have been relatively young
in that in that company yeah where is
the company had come from still hired
quite a lot of graduates and so I was
one of the more senior so yeah and so I
needed to sort of grow up a little bit
move to environment and then and then
maybe the businesses change but Berkeley
Mead at that point in time when I
suppose I was
what sort of twenty eight something like
that seemed like a much better culture
fit for me moving forwards because yeah
it was because it had that sort of
start-up feel to it but it had the big
company structure it's it sounded more
fun
it's a VPS you only truthful at the time
and I trusted Elliott on that because
like I said we'd always got along and so
I respected his judgment in in that
sense so it just felt like it had the
right the right kind of balance and at
that point PSD was was becoming a bit
style for me so I think it was yeah
there was a sort of personal yeah
personal timing I suppose so just having
clarity and what was right for you and
what was important to you at those
periods in your career basically a lot
of people a lot of people sometimes up
to you know you would have met way more
alacrity is the me that looking but I
think that's where sometimes a lot of
people can struggle isn't it having
complete complete clarity on what they
want our they're not next recruitment
role and and you haven't mentioned once
compared commissioner structure salary
or whatever talking about that you know
I mean it was I want to get access to
more people I'm not just the most
experienced I want to be the less
experienced I can and learn from more
people have more structure being a
bigger company and then the way that
you're talking about or C Berkeley means
as well so I think we're I think that's
the interesting part right that I think
it's about just having complete clarity
on or trying to have complete clarity on
what's important in your next stage of
your recruitment career yeah um okay so
only hunter green you started that so
obviously you so you started that just
just for context for everyone listening
you started that with three other people
I did yet so Elliott Laura and Sue okay
Elliott we've already mentioned so
Elliott was running the team
I worked in at Berkeley made and Laura
was also in that team okay and and Sue
was the director of the the office at
the London Business and so we had the
four of us obviously worked pretty
closely together Eliot Laura and I were
basically the sort of highest performing
team within that business and there was
a lot of changes so that business was
owned by the match tech group which
merged with our workers to become
Gattaca so there was there was a lot of
change going on at that point in time
consolidation your offices were closing
were moving it was it was just it was a
good time for us to consider stuff so as
Lewis change was going on we've been
talking about you know we could do this
we could do that kind of thing and just
you had conversations in the pub sort of
thing I was gonna say in the park most
likely yeah yeah and then and then the
change is kind of continued and we were
thinking will this actually but we might
you know there might be we don't know
what's gonna happen here we might we
might need to do something but at the
same time the business had totally
changed for the one that I joined they
feel hot recruiting so one of the
downsides right of the company that you
describe what it could be right that
those things long term it could these
the PSC's could change things straight
away or put more money into it and want
to take it to the next level and that
means that the consolidation change
that's one of the downsides right of a
big huge growing company yeah exactly
you've not got that much influence in
what's gonna happen and they just
totally went back to hiring graduates on
mass literally the office was being
stripped out things like that to create
more room for desk because it just
wasn't the same the model that I
originally joy and so we would talk
increasingly the conversations with a
little bit more I would remember what it
was like yeah
you know when we first joined and
couldn't we create something that was a
bit more like that and and those kind of
conversations and then as the almost as
it became more of a pressing issue we
started to formulate an actual plan and
then okay nice so I guess so
obviously that and so then took the leap
in 2015 right I mean yeah I think I've
been starting the business with three
other people sounds like a good idea and
and I mean there's loads of people there
that can add value in their own
different way I guess what what ended up
being this all of them first year plan
what what what did you guys end up
devising what do that did that look like
yeah so I would say that we had we kind
of did have a plan for the first year
and the plan really was to create a
business that we wanted to work for so
it was yeah what would that look like so
we had total flexibility you can work
from wherever you want you can work from
home you can work from hotel you can
work from flexible working space
whatever it whatever it is why was that
important to all of you try why was that
a shared importance we'd we'd seen
little bits in different businesses yet
really good things going on like it
might be flexibility or it might be
unlimited holiday or it might be really
competitive commission structures and
things like this but none of them had
all been together together yeah at the
same time and I mean certainly the flex
of the flexibility was something that
we've been given a sort of taste of a
barky made and then it had been whipped
away and so that was something that was
kind of at the forefront of our mind
something that was very important to us
and and we'd also work quite well in a
virus we knew that that had worked well
for us when it we're sure when it
happened so that that kind of led the
way and then we just look to create this
environment which we thought would act
as and
magnet to other recruits is like us so
then we would just create that and then
obviously everyone would want to come
and join and that would it would be that
simple yeah obviously that's not how it
played out so we did have a we did have
a plan to begin with and it was it was
the plan well obviously a huge
percentage of the UK recruitment
industry is made up of businesses of
your size so sub 9 staff yeah what was
the plan that was it did you officer you
been in the life of PSD bottling me that
clearly was aggressively growing was
sort of did we were all you guys on the
same page on right we want to build this
sort of lean sort of quote unquote
lifestyle business or is this something
that so we want to grow and scale like
what because I think that's also gonna
have an influence on on the plan so I
guess was that something that you was
all aligned with like what did you think
about that yeah it was it so it was
never supposed to be a lifestyle
business and it isn't and the plan has
always been to grow it but it has been
to grow it with consistent profitability
and it has been to grow it with in the
way we wanted to grow it which is to to
maintain recruiting more people like us
ideally that's that's what we're kind of
looking for is experience people who are
autonomous who could get real value out
of this kind of environment yeah where
that makes sort of scaling challenging
is that firstly not everyone wants to
work in a business that doesn't have an
office anyway so you've got your
candidate pool is reduced but secondly
we were acutely aware that this
environment isn't that conducive to
trait what it's not conducive in my view
at the moment at least to to training
new staff or even because well for a
years experience they need and deserve
much more than we could offer with this
set up so it's always good it was always
to be a sort of slow and steady approach
they say based on that but but you knew
but you all knew and shared the vision
that this was and we're not sort of
create flexibility so Alex can sort of I
don't know take the dog for a walk at 12
p.m. and have the kids at 11 a.m. and
then he can recruit sort of until 8 p.m.
whilst watching Coronation Street or
whatever do you not I mean it was it was
it was actually we wanted to build a
business with people like ours and the
things that you just described rather
than building the business around the
lifestyle that you wanted yeah for us as
directors yeah absolutely it was
the benefits are I mean the flexibility
works for us all in in different ways
providing you can you can deliver you
know you can you can use that as as you
need it really but it but it wasn't
really there for us it was for everyone
that was going to join the business you
know what those benefits were primarily
designed for and the idea is that the or
the theory is that people who can work
in whatever way works best for them
results in them being mentally and
physically much happier yeah and they do
a much much better job because of that
and they probably do that in the long
term and that probably hang around a lot
longer because they are able to do
things in the right way and and we do
have people have targets and they've
gotta hit those targets but providing
they hit those targets they can do it
however they want I can crack on now I
think let's just as we're talking about
it let's definitely just just really dig
into the flexible working piece just
because I know like because I just think
it's just really interesting right now I
think if you were to go on LinkedIn
every like every sink there's like at
least a poll a day on to would you
rather work from home fully would you
rather be back any obviously would
derive a couple days a week you know I
mean I think a lot of people listening
could get a lot of value out of this
because they're they're probably going
through this right now so as you said
you all want in flexibility from sort of
day one you want to build a business
that you wanted to work for you sort of
spoken about the types of people that
you wanted to attract and build the
business around so just to help me out
then and people listen and so from
pretty much year one then you you build
that flexible
business and it has been inflexible
fully remote business for the last five
years so let's just let's just sort of
uncover the the learnings you've all
you've just mentioned that definitely a
challenger on the training and
development side if we were to bring on
people that weren't autonomous maybe
aren't those experiences so they need to
do all you guys were what so what did so
what have you guys been doing over the
last five years and has it been five
days a week
fully remote or has it been sort of them
have you got a sort of office location
or what firstly what is a typical week
look like for the film full remote
business is it one day a week an office
I don't know what what did you what have
you guys been doing yeah good so it's
really varied I mean it's so we're in
town a lot we see each other quite quite
a bit in reality yeah well personally
I'm probably in two or three days in
town two or three days a week and
therefore I'll see a colleague probably
on one or two of those days at least we
make sure we get together as a group at
least once a month but in reality there
will be little pockets of people who are
yeah there are a lot more we use so yeah
I spend a lot of time working from home
from a home office but we spend time
together and talk co-working places we
use the Institute of Directors where we
can we can pitch up and work for the day
as a team face to face contact is is
really really really regular really
common we use Scott we use teams all the
time so it is not a case of being you
know it's not seven people working like
seven independent Cylons at home in in
any way and that was absolutely key for
us to ensure that there is a a culture
here within the business a sort of
virtual one almost which revolves around
what's at groups teams meetings you know
physical meetings but ultimately they
have the flexibility to work
from home or wherever that suits them at
a given time so they're much more in
control of their community yeah sure so
let's just talk because I think a lot of
a lot of recruiters will start to
experience this and they're sort of
working we might start looking like how
you just described it compared to been
in the office five days a week right so
guess some of this all of them some of
the real learnings that you've been free
then over the last sort of good number E
is of sort of doing this so I think one
of the challenges and concerns
definitely is the culture piece which
you've just touched on can I can I build
a code from my team or my recruitment
business if they're out of the office
most the time so it seems like how
you've done that is made sure that it's
a collaborative team it's not everyone
sort of lone wolf doing what they need
to do so I guess anything sort of any
key points or any key things that you've
learned that you think that has had a
real impact on the development of your
business culture besides the whatsapp
groups besides the face-to-face meeting
sometimes anything else that you solve
implemented or do consistent as a
business that you think's really helped
impact that yeah I mean I think that the
culture of the business has always been
what it internally has always been one
that puts people first so it's always
been about ensuring so I touched on the
earlier sort of happiness and
healthiness on with the theory that
those people who are happy and healthy
are going to do a great job yeah really
really simply so we we try to make sure
we've got a sort of well-being ethos
running through as much of what we do as
is possible
so that that that really does vary to be
honest but that might be just sort of
casually sharing plenty of well-being
and wellness tips to sort of officially
try to encourage something new on a
monthly basis across the team to make
sure people are looking out for each
other but but beyond all that is trying
to trying to foster a culture of
openness where people can be
really really open in the business but I
think this is really key at the moment
but where people can be really really
open about how they're feeling any
challenges there they're up against
whatever that may be it might be
personal it might be work-wise but where
they can really be open about that so we
can work on it and and overcome it you
know together and that I think that the
idea of there is that generally that has
brought people together people feel more
comfortable being themselves and less
scared of displaying a weakness as it
might be sure to be perceived you know
we really try to stamp out any any kind
of thinking like that like that there is
such a thing as you know a weakness on
that level that is what we tried really
hard to do and we and we do that by
trying to reciprocate right so if I
doing that ourselves putting ourselves
out there if you have an affair day we
try to be honest about it and that has
led to an environment or a culture where
people believe so it's not we're not
just saying that we're actually in there
and I mean yeah and so to what I believe
what yeah I'll get why is um why is it
openness so important when your team
might be fully remote or is remote quite
a lot at the time and you don't get that
like wise wise openness important why is
that something that you guys have
doubled down on yeah a major part of
that is just because you can't see
people right so you can't you know can't
see someone's body language you maybe
you don't have maybe as much in reality
but ever as much interaction so you
don't get to see this okay partaking in
a conversation you know those inverted
comments that sort of water cooler
conversations and that kind of things
you maybe don't get those those little
snippets that gives you an indication as
to whether someone's having a bad day so
in a way you have I've asked them and
and encouraged them to feel comfortable
in telling you which is quite difficult
but over time when when people see that
other people are doing that
it begins to feel comfortable in doing
that and and that's that that's the
theory is there ya know that that's
great and I guess what's coming up for
me is and if I'm listening to this I may
be a leader or even a recruitment
business owner and I know that's
important but Alex Cooper my below I
feel like something might be up but he's
just not what I can't get him to open up
I think that that's a quite common
challenge right so you've got the right
intention this is something you want to
foster you want to over communicate and
you're being sort of vocal in yourself
but what of I'm sure you've encountered
that right where like I'll see you
clinically it's important to you guys
but you might have someone that maybe
taken a bit more time or maybe isn't
used to being so open and sharing their
vulnerability is how have you gone about
sort of them cultivating someone that
maybe not be so willing to open up to
open up I'm certainly not a you know an
expert in any way the examples you know
such and yeah that absolutely does
happen especially I would say you know
when you're recruiting more experienced
people who've spent ten fifteen years in
recruitment working in businesses which
aren't very open to this kind of you
know to these exactly so we are kind of
exposed to people who might be less
comfortable in it in a way I don't know
from for me or for us he's just been
working really hard to reassure people
internally that you know if you're
having a bad day you're not gonna lose
your job you know you don't need to
worry about that kind of thing yeah yeah
yeah we all have bad days that's all I
can say really is it's been a case of
just trying to constantly reassure
understand listen as much as possible
put yourselves out there and yeah I mean
that's that's all we've done really our
concern oh yeah I mean I mean over what
you said knows that it starts with you
buyers and that might even that might
even be a challenge for people that will
actually I know it's important but I
might demonstrating that myself
if I if I join your business and then
you and the free other business owners
are sort of sharing and we want one and
that what's our group or whatever it may
be that you had a really [ __ ] day this
is why the I don't know I'm going to be
way more inclined to sort of share those
things and open up if I see my leaders
and the business opening up and lead
them by example and this yeah it starts
from the top right yeah absolutely and I
think that's I think that is in any in
any business which is the you know is
trying to sort of deliver a well-being
strategy or mental health strategy or
whatever you want to call it it has got
to run through every fiber of the
business exactly if there's no point in
it being something to satisfy the
shareholders if it's not being executed
at a managerial level talking on a
really big scale it can't just be
something that you talk about but don't
do on a much smaller scale like ours
it's got to be it's gotta be ingrained
in the culture and I suppose that's what
I would say that we tried to do I mean
we we educate ourselves on it and I'll
have you but clearly we're not we're not
experts are sales of course okay so I
think another another part on the
flexibility piece that people that
typically have always worked in the
office would find difficult obviously
specific to recruitment businesses sort
of having the eyes on how your team are
doing like when you're in the office you
can have a way more sense of how people
did in that be deep hour hour or
whatever do you not I mean so I guess I
think a lot of people get a lot of value
from you sort of sharing how you've gone
about sort of what you've put in place
in terms of processes or sort of what
things you've put in place or what
things you always keep an eye on as a
business the key and indicators that so
you're giving you your guy's the best
everyone's doing what they need to to
get the outcomes that you guys want as a
business so I guess how have you gone
about measuring and the visit that
having visibility on people being
efficient people doing what they need to
do I don't know what's been your journey
with that yeah oh that's a really
interesting that's a really interesting
question because it
different different answers to that
because because that is something that
we haven't done very well historically
if I'm completely honest with you well
you know not well so the guys that have
been successful that we cuz we've got
amazing core team and they've all yeah
they've all done better in this
environment they've done previously
they've all had you know their record
billion years as individuals in a
completely fully remote environment from
what you've discussed from what you've
shared already so yeah in working
working at only starter green they have
better dead right comparison five days
of it okay cool cool yeah so it clearly
it works for them it works for us
as directors as well and and the
original sort of layout of the business
was that you know you've got your only
KPI is your target right your target is
focus or your target is four times your
base salary and you hit that target
working one day a year or 365 days a
year and and and you know you can have
as much flexibility around it as you
want was the kind of real real basic
okay yeah a few on that and if there are
any issues we would work backwards and
look through the code you've got CRM
system things are recorded but we don't
measure any of those things okay but we
will investigate them if something's
gone wrong so if there's an issue we'll
look at those and we'll try to identify
where that problem is and then coach and
around those areas to try and rectify
that and which which is all good and
well so that's the way we've been
operating this you've had one clear
outcome-based target which is low Alex
so together I think we agree that your
your target should be this four times
your salary or whatever how you do that
is completely up to you and we're not
going to be looking every day how many
calls you made blah blah blah but so the
outcome target that you have is that and
that sort of that's well you have to hit
or that's that's the only thing needs to
be concerned
yeah exactly and if you run in at 70 80
% of that then let's let's have a look
at where maybe things have changed to
improve and I say that's worked really
well for the for the guys that they're
here but where we were where we could
have done a lot better is by having
better better processes in in place
sorry I was just bringing me on Team
North we could have had them we could
have had a lot better processes in place
to onboard them and develop people that
weren't necessarily going to take to
this like a duck to water and okay the
next question is how do you know whether
someone's going to take to it like a
duck to water and that comes in to their
past experience and the interview
process and how you assess them coming
into the business as to sort of what's
going to be required for them and that's
where we've we've missed out in the past
is we haven't had enough structure in
those processes to help people in in
this current environment some people are
just gonna they're gonna beg a fly in it
yeah so we'll get hated so what you've
had to get better at is on that
onboarding process or during the
interview process even identifying where
they're gonna need support potentially
and going them to this type of
environment with any doubt yeah exactly
because it's not it really isn't for
everyone and and the biggest I think the
biggest learning for us is that
just because you it suits you doesn't
mean he's gonna sue everyone else would
be very nice yeah I'm ways around that
and in some ways a little bit spoiled by
one or two hires coming in and nailing
it and you know it makes you think oh
yeah this is this is great and it's not
yeah I mean basically it basically not
not having enough rigor in those yeah in
those interview processes to to identify
people that are ya gonna need more help
there are a lot of people that obviously
are attracted to this kind of working
model because you know in in many ways
it's for certain people we do believe is
the ideal working environment you know
if you need love you need flexibility
we've got one of them one of the most
flexible models in the industry that we
know but that is open to abuse right
because if you're not disciplined then
it doesn't suit you
it's not going to be right for you but
you still but it doesn't mean you're
aware of that right yeah and some people
are and they just know it's not for them
and and that's great but there's yeah
and some people know it's going to be
right for them but there is a large you
know portion of people out there who
think it's gonna be right but it's not
and we didn't do enough to what was the
common areas identify that what's the
common areas that people typically need
help then that you've learnt from is it
is it typically one or two you call
things that people realize well actually
this is something near this isn't my
strongest point or this is what I find
most challenging about being in that
type of environment is it discipline is
it sort of actually I need a bit of
process and I need someone sort of give
me a bit of Management I don't know
what's the what's the typical thing that
people don't realize I am it's
definitely a mixture but discipline is
definitely one of them I think
I think there's also a source there's an
awareness factor within people's to
saying looking at themselves and
identifying how much of their discipline
is self-generated and how much of it is
generally by the office environment that
you're in
Merstham and you need to know that you
need to honestly know look in the mirror
and say yeah like you need to know the
answer to that question if you look
going into a fully flexible environment
don't you absolutely and anyway that
cuts both ways we need to we need to be
yeah yeah cause cover that as well of
course but and yeah absolutely because
you could yeah if it's not right for you
then it and you're not you're not
disciplined but you can't you generate
that yourself you could really take a
step back in this kind of environment
mmm that's interesting so let's all tie
this together I know we really dug deep
into the flexible working piece a
because I know this is something that I
mean it was a core part as to what you
want to build a business around and as I
said I think it's just so valuable right
now you're talking about your learnings
and experiences in this what are with
most businesses now most likely from
what I'm seeing the conversations I'm
having to have way more flexibility in
terms of sort of what a typical week
might look like for their recruitment
business what are the most common
misconceptions people have on having
more flexibility like what what are the
most common misconceptions recruiters
have when it comes to more flexible
working or remote working a promote
consultant perspective yeah
maybe that that's a good question I mean
maybe that is easier oh yeah maybe that
is easier but by that I mean I think
that makes these kind of relates to what
we were just talking about because I
think maybe people think well you know
I'm going to get up as early or I can
yeah this school run or I can go to
things that you hear on there yeah
exactly and there's you know there's
absolutely nothing wrong with that
providing you are you you aren't you
have some structure to to your day and
ensure that you do everything that needs
to be done yeah and sometimes when these
things are so literally physically close
oh whatever that may be it can be really
difficult to maintain that so it's very
easy to say well look I'm gonna write
this stuff in my Outlook diary and stick
to it or I've got a daily planner I'll
just work through all of that before I
go and do something else but that's
where quite often the office environment
you know bit subconsciously or because
the way that you know I don't know maybe
this you've got a manager basically
making sure you're doing certain things
yeah okay but it can quite easily you
can pick them quite easily I think it
dragged into doing things that you know
could be more distracted yeah you don't
know until you've tried it and that's
kind of one of the great great things
all they're under you know obviously all
from circumstances but one of the great
things from a remote working perspective
over the last ten weeks or so is that
people have been forced to work out
whether they can do it or not exactly
and so we will see a lot more whether
people are suited to this on them so how
is this then tie this together how is
this then had Locker how is this really
then impacted what your recruitment
business is achieved and sort of what
type of recruitment business you've been
able to build over the last five years
then because it's definitely not a
typical as you said it Steph Stefan
typical recruitment business where
you've got full remote team but I think
there's going to be more of sort of and
I think there's definitely a blend are
motional criminal base is going to be
for the remote not sure I think there's
definitely a lot of recruitment
businesses that are going to be a blend
so I guess from some of your experience
would have been would have been sort of
the great things about building a
recruitment business like you have yeah
so all of the everything we just talked
about in regards to learn it all came
through our you know basically the
mistakes that we made when it came to
hiring and the lack of rigor and you
know that we had within our hiring
process to ensure that we were bringing
in people bringing in people that would
well-suited genuinely well-suited to
this environment or if there was a sort
of borderline element where they would
really keep weak we didn't give them
enough support to make sure that they
were so that that learning has come from
you know look basically a few failures
in hiring people and keeping them on
board which has inevitably stunted some
of the growth clan so we had a
realization a couple of years back we
sort of had a year of we've grown every
year first three years is kind of steady
growth and then year four we grew might
intend on on year three so massive sort
of point of stagnation and we realized
that we needed to make some changes so
we started recently created a new vision
we've really sort of refocused on where
we really need to be prioritizing as
individual recruiters we had to make a
couple of changes you know alternately
in the team and we've started investing
more money in our processes in our
recruit recruitment process more testing
we've got a much better but we think
we've got a far far better process in
place now to enable us to grow more
moving forwards both in terms of
interviewing and onboarding
but it is the lack of that in the past
which has stunted that growth growth
yeah but how do you think that if you
were to if you were to grow if you would
have in the in those first three to four
years you would have grown sort of your
creamerum is like a typical way
everyone's in an office in London might
maybe got potentially more heads but do
you think you would have been more
profitable doing that all be more
profitable the way that you've done it
and I mean certainly there's elements of
our model reduced overheads essentially
which which do help when it comes to the
bottom line I don't I I don't know is
the honest answer we I don't think in
hindsight that we ever we well we never
not at one point that we ever look at
sort of doing that basically so it was
always a very based around flexibility
we did look at a couple of lots or
satellite office type things to just to
give people a base but then we went down
there sort of membership routes yeah and
so we changed it on that level but I
don't think we were ever going to do it
so it's almost one of those impossible
questions to answer
yeah definitely a definitely thing there
would be one or two people that we
joined our business and then left it
which who would have been more
successful in that environment that's in
fun but at the same time yes maybe some
of the guys wouldn't have had a record
years might have you just wouldn't know
so I really I really don't know but I
know that we believe in this and that we
wouldn't have well that we haven't
considered that hmm too much so I think
as you sort will come to the end of this
I guess a lot of people will be thinking
about and clearly it's something that
you've had to refine invest money in and
sort of learn from your mistakes but I
think that onboarding part is going to
be a lot of people are in this or
struggle and visualize what that might
look like or they'll probably have to go
through those mistakes that you went
through if they're sort of onboarding
new recruiters for their business so I
yes what yeah what would this sort of
non-negotiables for your onboarding
process now that have had a real impact
on making sure that people really do get
the platform and the support and go
through that process of giving the best
possible chance of sort of starting the
right way in this environment what what
are the non-negotiable was there from
that you love from your mistakes yeah I
think the I think sort of there's
there's when you join a new company
that's obviously one big change for you
if you're moving from a business which
in which you've been predominantly in an
office to being predominantly working
remotely or flexibly that's another
massive change and I don't think we gave
enough acknowledgement to the fact that
you were sort of having a change really
on there and a level of change that
people were experiencing and so when
recruiting we recruit experienced
recruiters there is there's an element
of you know you obviously that they are
experienced they know what they're doing
and and they don't need hand-holding
necessarily that's that's probably the
wrong wrong terminology but no I know
you mean the only we probably didn't
well certainly I don't think and this is
something we will change we didn't have
enough contacts basically in the early
stages so obviously in an office
environment people to give it a plan
they might be part of a team and a lot
of their the structure and discipline
and rigor around their comes from being
in that environment it works really well
clearly and we we tried to probably go a
little bit too far the other way and
kind of yeah we'd be there you know
absolutely and don't get me wrong people
would still have plenty of contact but I
think more structure is required than
the normal normally earth be when items
join in a business and working remotely
because of it being a totally well not
totally but but quite often a very very
alien working environment yeah so what
do those first couple of weeks look like
now then cuz I get I'll tell you again
sense of it's like other notes they
obviously have the touch points and
whatever but and then is it other no
weak one they're getting sent Alex's
best tip they've all they you send them
a document rates like this is what I've
learnt over the last five years and what
structure works for me
these are some of the things that you
should probably thinking about these are
some of the things that you probably
want to work out over the next couple of
weeks that will really give you the best
chance of yeah long-term success like
what what things have you included then
the can understand interest in that
because I think a lot of people will get
value out of that yeah they would and so
it I for knew exactly what it says
because we just said basically we've
just been working with an external
consultants and fully developed that so
we were at final interview stages with
several people when Kovac came in and we
haven't actually been able to unboard
anyone or make any offer we didn't make
any offers we pulled all the processes
on hold while we worked out what the
extent of the damage was going to be so
we haven't actually onboarding people I
could dig it out and tell you but I we
certainly are we certainly believe in it
and it's been it's been professionally
developed within I think now I think the
learn in there which I think a lot of
people get a lot of value out of is they
don't fall into this or camp will be
naive that our Alex has got five years
experience you know as always doing so
sort of anything more than the typical
touch points and making sure it gets
interesting the rest of the team and
blah blah blah yeah I guess don't fall
into the camp that's just what's
required and don't yeah don't be naive
that will actually remember that this
person is going from a work environment
that they've sort of been console with
and used to for the last five years and
that they're now completely changing and
they're joining the new company so I
think that's the interesting thing which
is why you need to invest in the things
that you're investing and really get
better at that onboarding piece yeah and
it's certainly it's it's absolutely it's
absolutely key to get it right we we
think we've now got a process that will
be successful
I'm excited to see whether that is
successful but it is absolutely key and
it one thing we can say is that we had
we hadn't necessarily got there right
previously so yeah that's why it so what
what's the vision then before we finish
what where where do you see this sort of
fully remote fully flexible recruitment
business going what the plans well I
mean the vision for the company is to
take that sort of what the original plan
for the company was to actually create a
business that people wanted to work for
the vision but a company now is to go in
and help our clients to achieve that so
it's working across all touch points of
the employment lifecycle
so just recruit a branding employer
branding attraction recruitment
onboarding development attention and
even exit so it's it's taking that out
to our clients and helping to consult
and advise across all of those touch
points not just the recruitment piece so
the future for our business is to expand
our service lines and and become more of
us or holistic consultancy of course all
of those improvement touch points rather
than just purely on the recruitment
front and and we don't really see and it
will be it will be very very interesting
to see what you know how the world
changes when when lockdowns are released
and the way the world works looks beyond
this but so I might change what I'm
about to say but coming into it we
didn't really see anything changing it's
about getting those getting those
processes a lot a lot stronger and more
effective and more efficient to make
sure people are going to be successful
in the environment and continuing to
invest a lot we're going to be where we
are investing a lot more money in
development learning coaching and sales
training all of these things and still
looking to deliver a lot of that
remotely so it's really sort of
enhancing the remote environment rather
than just mmm creating yeah creating
I suppose you could look at it as a work
from home environment it is not that it
is inflexible remote working environment
but we need to enhance it that's clearly
the journal that you've been on which
nothing was really interested in and
okay before I actually the last question
then what and what are you most excited
to do after COBIT so he's getting it's
absolutely picking up those recruitment
processes typically as possible and and
growing this business as I said we had
it we had a year of consolidation but we
had our record year as a result of it so
we were in a really good really good
position to invest that money in
expanding the business and that's yeah
absolutely it couldn't come at a worse
time but we're still really excited
about about about that in the future
cool so I know it's been a bit of a
slightly different episode really gone
into the the flexible working piece but
I think and the remote working piece of
it I think so many people get so much
value out of that but obviously before
the last question and it's more in more
than half of people to reach out and
maybe pick your brain or ask for advice
on yeah more maybe get a bit more detail
on the learnings or things like that
because a lot of people going to be
going through what you guys have been
for in the last five years and what
you've had to get there and prove that
etc yeah yeah absolutely we have bit if
it's you have people who want to talk
about how to how to set that up and
manage people or if who's consultants
that want to talk about how to manage
your day anything yeah so lots and final
question Alex you can answer it with a
phrase a sentence or words whatever
comes up for you but if you could
communicate to every single recruiter
out there
they'd listen to Alex they take on your
advice they implemented tomorrow what
would you say to the people
yeah I think work hard be honest and be
be genuine and be yourself because if
you're not if you can't be successful
you can't on enjoy your job being
yourself you're on borrowed time anyway
mmm Alex it's been a pleasure thank you
thank you